et maintenant j'accueille gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
politique élections à villeneuve sur lot
et cette très bonne nouvelle le ps reste
quand même troisième parti de france
non ils sont devant les verts et
mélenchon s'est
en même temps l'autre côté françois
fillon dans les alpes maritimes il cite
les grandes inventions françaises le
soutif et le béton c'est que des trucs
qui empêche de bouger
fillon à la tête de l'état son plan de
réforme ça va s'appeler le livre blanc
de la camisole
international c'était le g8 cette
semaine c'est intéressant le g8 s'est
tué ses sept endroits où des
technocrates sans cravate vient de se
faire humilier par un russe le scrupule
en gros le g8 s'est un peu c'est un back
room sm tenu par un cause à la
démocratie toujours
en iran le progressiste a gagné ça va
faire bouger les choses on prendra
toujours les homosexuels mais avec une
corde rose
bakari baya
le bac coûte 1,5 milliard d'euros quel
gâchis ça coûte cher informé des
chômeurs à ce prix là c'est vraiment
alors j'ai regardé les sujets du bac en
histoire un sujet très intéressant la
france est un état qui conserve
aujourd'hui une certaine influence à
l'échelle du monde justifier cette
affirmation en donnant deux arguments
bas lol mdr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas très grave les profs ont été
invités à surnoter à l'épreuve de
français ça c'est une bonne idée faire
croire des débiles qu'ils ont compris
rousseau alors qu'ils sont incapables de
résumé marc levy
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un texte de jean jacques goldman a été
proposé au bacon français va s'arrêter
pour l'épreuve de musique j'aurais été
plus surpris quoi
la discipline reine reste la philo avec
ce truc le travail permet-il de prendre
conscience de soi non y'a qu'à voir
zahia elle a déclaré que son métier
c'était courtisane et non pas prostituée
je veux dire c'est un voyage je suis
courtisane elle a lu la définition
et moi je lui dis je les ai vu la
différence entre une prostituée une
courtisane selon wikipedia qu'elles sont
plus lettrés et elle vivait avec des
écrivains des artistes des aristocrates
ah oui c'est vrai que quand tu voi sa
clientèle à zahia c'est pile dans la
définition
[Applaudissements]
et
ribéry benzema la première chose qui me
vient à l'esprit c'est l'arbre
généalogique des bourbons rodin victor
hugo
zahia dont les confidences télévisuelles
ont fait plus d'audience que
l'intervention de hollande dans capital
mais ça s'explique pas les français
préfèrent la pratique à la théorie entre
un type qui dissertent sur le chômage
des jeunes est une qui a trouvé la
solution pour en sortir
non m hollande dans un magazine de m6
faire avant l'été sur tf1 et m6 la suite
c'est quoi ça on dirait le parcours d'un
candidat déchu de la télé réalité
la prochaine étape ça va être les
corréziens à mykonos
[Applaudissements]
scolarité toujours un prof a commis des
attouchements hors cadre scolaire alors
on accable mais je trouve que c'est
assez sympa on sait bien aux abymes job
c'est horrible c'est on sent le truc qui
tâche enfin musique j'ai été un peu dur
avec johnny la dernière fois j'ai dit
que son guitariste devait jouer devant
5000 blaireau je retire ce que j'ai dit
ils étaient beaucoup plus nombreux venu
à john isner faut arrêter quoi le type
mais des costumes à paillettes il fait
l'amour à un micro ils se déhanchent à
ce rythme là dans dix ans il fait du
rock quoi
amour
pourquoi je me balance je pense qu'on a
retrouvé l'auteur de la princesse de
clèves ah ça doit être christine lagarde
qui a aussi dû signer les liaisons
dangereuses parce que c'est le monde
publie une lettre un peu olé olé très
bon le monde qui invente la paparazzade
de la pièce à conviction ce peu importe
bref comme tout le monde j'ai été choqué
par cette lettre était utilise mois
guide moi c'est très bourgeois aucune
fantaisie la part d'une directrice du
fmi moi je pensais trouver des halles
engage un peu plus fleuri comme c'est
pas moi viens injecte de la liquidité
dans mon déficit intérieur
relance la compétitivité de met aux
fourneaux
baisse les charges sociales dans ma
culotte
justice
deux décisions formidable alors les
agresseurs du rer d ont eu des peines de
prison avec sursis alors que le militant
anti mariage gay vient d'être condamné à
deux mois de prison ferme c'est génial
la justice français c'est c'est super
pédagogue d'un côté on empêche ceux qui
dépouillent de mu formé en prison et
d'un autre côté on permet à ceux qui
refusent les rapports au mode à les
approfondir le sujet
[Applaudissements]
formidable travail
fait divers brosseau sud en
nouvelle-zélande une femme de 36 ans qui
s'est fait engrosser par un gosse de 11
ans 11 ans
tient la barre 11 ans déjà cessé d
hommes bah maintenant tu comprends
pourquoi avec une précocité pareil il
met 30 à 0 à l'équipe de france de rugby
[Applaudissements]
en australie toujours le sud une
australienne qui parle avec un accent
français après un accident de voiture
c'est un cas bizarre mais bon les
scientifiques se pencherait maintenant
sur un cas encore plus rare un français
qui parlerait anglais sans accent
bonne nouvelle à terminant alors on a
des nouvelles de pardieu il veut une
nationalité supplémentaires je sais pas
quoi j'imagine que c'est dans le cadre
d'un plan défiscalisation parce qu'à
force de cumuler les endroits de séjour
il va bientôt payer ses impôts à l'onu
alors
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il mettait un
peu de bleu